let's say that I have a geometric series
only a geometric sequence I should say
we'll talk about series in a second so a
geometric series let's say it starts at
one and then our common ratio is 1/2 so
the common ratio is the number that we
keep multiplying by so 1 times 1/2 is
1/2 1/2 times 1/2 is 1/4 1/4 times 1/2
is 1/8 and we can keep going on and on
and on forever this is an infinite
geometric sequence and we can denote
this we can say that this is equal to
the sequence of a sub n from N equals 1
to infinity with with a sub n equaling
equaling 1 times our common ratio to the
N minus 1 so it's going to be our first
term which is just 1 times our common
ratio which is 1/2 1/2 to the N minus 1
and you can verify this right over here
you can view is 1/2 to the 0 power this
is 1/2 to the first power this is 1/2
squared or 1/2 to the first this is 1/2
squared so the first term is 1/2 to the
0 the second term is 1/2 to the 1 the
third term is 1/2 squared so the nth
term is going to be 1/2 to the n minus 1
so this is just really 1/2 to the n
minus 1 power
fair enough now let's say we don't just
care about looking at the sequence we
actually care about the sum of the
sequence so we actually care about not
just looking at each of these terms see
what happens if I keep multiplying by
1/2 but I actually care about summing 1
plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 and keep
going on and on and on forever so this
we would now call a geometric series and
because I keep adding an infinite number
of terms this is an infinite geometric
series so this right over here would be
the infinite geometric geometric series
a series you can just view as the sum of
a sequence now how would we denote this
well we can use summing notation we
could say that this is equal to the sum
we could say that this is equal to the
sum let me make sure I'm not falling off
the page
go over to the left of route the sum
from N equals one to infinity of a sub N
and a sub n is just one half to the N
minus one one half to the N minus one
power so you just say okay what N equals
one it's 1/2 to the 0 which is 1 then
I'm going to sum that to when N equals 2
which is 1/2 when N equals 3 it's 1/4 on
and on and on and on so all I want to do
in this video is to really clarify
differences between sequences and series
and make you a little bit comfortable
with the notation in the next few videos
we'll actually try to take sums of
geometric series and see if we actually
get a finite value